hey i teased giving harvard fifty
thousand dollars to take zoom classes
uh i don't know if i even have to ask
your guys opinions on this
no but what
crazy but who's gonna pay that's my
thing is like
and then we're gonna watch people pay
for it people are gonna do this right so
this just shows you how bankrupt and
insane higher education is that they
would have the audacity to charge people
fifty thousand dollars
for this and that is what a racket it is
right
right it makes no sense and then they
say they're going to test it might have
been i can't remember it was them or
someone else that they're going to test
students
every two days and take away sports
it's like no sports which is like your
d1
and then you're going to test people
every two days
come on i don't underst wait i i got
tested and it was not great
i didn't enjoy having that thing stuck
in the oh i did two of the um
blood tests and they both came back
negative there's some new tests coming
that are going to be dope though where
you're going to be able to like do a
swab
that's not like the deep crazy swab and
in 15 minutes for 10 bucks you get it so
maybe that's part of their banking on an
easier test but still
here's an idea what if harvard instead
said it's 5k
and uh we're gonna open the door and
anyone who wants to have a harvard
education for 5k you're on zoom can do
it
and the whole world should show up
because education should be open and
we're no longer
constrained by buildings and we're not
greedy and we do have a great brand we
already have 40 billion
in our endowment or whatever it is let's
just go teach people let's go invest in
actual education of everyone that we can
if we think we're so special that would
be
revolutionary game changing progressive
interesting and it would also help so
many people
leg up because they have at harvard on
their resume forever to your point
alex you're saying if you're so good at
teaching
teach more people teach more people it's
on zoom guys you can do more than 20
people on a call
but instead harvard wants to maintain
the exclusivity because they're jerks
and because they're selfish and greedy
and not focused on education they're
focused on maintaining their own
hegemony in the education market
globally it's not great
so i don't understand doing that when
their endowment is so large so it's like
the interest on your endowment
you can wait a year you can skip a year
is it really
that expensive to operate it's like
you're going to go in a deficit anyways
having people on campus
and having food service and all these
other things it doesn't make any sense
and so the expectation is you put the
a bunch of young people into dorms
and they sit on their computers and they
watch zoom and then you're trusting
that none of them are going to kiss each
other at any point in time
oh that was ridiculous or go on a date
right like i kind of think right they're
like you can't go into each other's
dorms only people in the dorms
in the dorm itself can stay in that dorm
come on yeah that would last 12 hours
why am i here
right yeah i kind of think maybe
somebody might there might be some
necking going on in college somebody
might get a little kissy kissy
so here's the question yeah what is the
use case for why someone would say okay
i'll see you see you there my parents
are so
rich and i am so entitled
that i just want a harvard sweatshirt
and
logo on my linkedin page i mean that's
really what we're saying here
because you could watch the same videos
on
are they on coursera or edx or whatever
it is like yeah they're on one of them
they're on one of them so
they've always been on those mit also is
like
mit put all their stuff online and there
was this one kid i don't know if you
read about this
he took every mit course um for his like
masters in
ai or something wrote all the
documentation down
and i was talking and i've told the
story before here i was talking to
somebody who's you know very famous in
the industry and i said would you take
that person who took all the courses on
their own and document it and put it in
a manila folder and hand it to you
or somebody who went there and he's like
of course i take the former i want the
person who was the hustler
and this person's writing a book about
it by the way on how he did that and i
think it's
i was actually having this debate with
my wife and i was talking to her about
how like
everybody has access to youtube now
every skill you could want to learn is
on youtube
there are some ways in which the world
has gotten demonstrably better
for learning skills and still people are
watching five hours of television at
night
uh the average american watch is five
hour four or five hours of television to
this day
when i meet young people and they're
like hey what should i do i'm like stop
watching television for two years and
learn how to
code be a designer be a salesperson
anything
just get any course you can get and just
load up on skills
so the accreditation makes is making
less and less sense and i thought the
whole like people buying their way into
ivy league schools with like
photoshopped
photos would end this nonsense where
people are just the idea of
credentialing is over this feels like
the last
you know okay so yes but if you're white
if you're not white i think the
credential what
yeah you took the words out of my mouth
like
i think people still need credentials
and need that stamp of approval i mean
you do hmm absolutely i wouldn't got a
stamp of approval as a startup
i was like you know what i don't care
how good our company is i still need one
little
silicon valley stamp of approval like
what 500 startups or yc
or like some advice your 500 startups so
you get a little logo
you know you get the little logo you
have your little demo day guaranteed
techcrunch article like you just have to
play the game
no matter you can't be too naive to
think that you're going to be the one
who didn't have to play the game
i just feel like this skills are so
you know especially with remote work now
like
because we're not in the same offices
the person who just gets something done
very quickly and sends you the result
it feels like that's the person who's
going to win i don't maybe i'm naive but
like if you're not there yet you're
close jason there's a leveling you're
you're directionally accurate i think
your right credentials are losing their
their their power i have many friends
that don't have college degrees that are
doing very well
i think your right skills and competence
are the things that matter
but we're in this little circle here and
a lot of people outside of the circle
are still essentially operating like
they always have and they need you know
four year degree or at least two years
in the right direction
today you know we're not doctors we're
not lawyers we're not accountants we're
not
also in professional for degree if
there's a certification like brain
surgery yeah you're not going to learn
on youtube
like this there are the the um
[Music]
there have been some people who have
learned how to fly on simulators and on
youtube and then
stolen planes like this has become like
a bit of a thing
and in med school they do simulations
and 3d stuff
and i mean they do that in med school
too i think this was in a science
fiction film
or i'm sorry a science fiction novel
where some kid
basically in the simulator got so good
at surgery
that they became the greatest surgeon
ever because they were just
you know it's almost like um ender's
game remember ender's game
i don't know spoiler alert but it's not
a video game this is the real world
so it's interesting to see that my wife
is now in her fourth year of residency
and uh she just finished her year three
so i'm living with someone who's going
through this really advanced credential
credentialing process i think for for
those sorts of jobs
we should maintain kind of the current
system as it is but for everything else
we should tear it down
especially down to weird things like
like hair technicians and so forth that
are that are
kept out of work by you know really
ridiculous
um government uh rules and regulations
that are that are asinine
and they're always somehow uh much more
hard to get than to become a police
officer which is uh
um done who would have thought
yeah well and there we are at policing i
mean that's
the ultimate one where we have to
rethink it um
yep we don't have enough time on this
show no
yeah you know it's interesting i was
there was a time period i don't know
maybe four or five years ago i was
starting to see a lot of
uh non-lethal policing
um equipment so
like you know guns where you shoot a net
guns that don't kill you that you know
all this kind of stuff
and then you just think about it it's
like yeah none of that stops somebody
who kneels on somebody's neck for
for eight minutes and just murders them
and suffocates them like
not this isn't even an issue of somebody
being shot with a gun